[music]
we are currently swapping the situation for
will that means we swap
one of the sunflowers or rapeseed oil for
one behind me the whole thing is the
idea let's just come up with the oil
or gas has to be small and therefore
[music]
listen to each other  very difficult
because this supermarket is working with your
private policy and also in
smaller quantities and the man 300
apartments to get
no longer support
the customers are super satisfied
that helped us helped they helped
us we are happy about everyone
liters of oil and 10 minutes even
one arrives from ukraine with between 80
liters has been exchanged like a
omniscient happy and admit
i brought 80 liters of sunflower oil with me now the actions here
and then after 80 liters of beer
we get eight crates  are all
a bit mixed are white like a
bit light must radler
and jan i find the reak  tion mega because
it's just for everyone true we get
cheap beer and this price
also helps because
there is an oil shortage in Germany at the moment and
so it's of course a great opportunity for everyone
[music]